[Music]
is it unreasonable to want your spouse
to be your best friend my spouse asked
me to not talk about my work anymore he
said it's all we talk about all he hears
all day is complaining from his work so
the last thing he wants to hear when he
gets home is more complaining or
excuses woo what's up this is John with
Dr John deloney
show show about your marriage your
parenting your kids your mental health
your emotional health whatever you got
going on in your life my promise is I
may not know the answer but I'll sit
with you and we will figure it out and
we're going to reach out to the people
who um might be experts but we're going
to land on an answer here's what you
need to do next if you want to be on
this show this shows real people going
through real challenges give me a buzz
at 1844 693 32 291 it's 1844 693 3291 or
go to john.com askk and do
not um miss the end of this show make
sure you find some time and some space
to watch this to listen to the end of
the show we got something special for
you coming up at the very end um in the
space of the last caller and I'm super
excited this is episode 489 we just
recorded out of order this morning our
500th episod episode with a very very
very special guest super
jazzed and I might see her later tonight
at our
house and I don't mean that in the Koy
but I do mean that in the koi no I do
whatever let's go to Little Rock and
talk to Dear Marie what's up
Marie hi Dr John how are you party and
what are you up to oh live in the dream
sometimes it's a nightmare anytime
somebody says live in the dream their
life is terrible what's up
well I'll just get straight to my
question um I wanted to know is it
unreasonable to want your spouse to be
your best friend and
Confidant um it depends on your
definition of best
friend well um my spouse basically asked
me to not talk about my work anymore um
I'm sorry I'm really nervous I'm shaking
my don't be nervous Mary I'm terrible at
this we're
fine um he said it's all we talk about
and all he hears all day is complaining
from his work so the last thing he wants
to hear when he gets home is more
complaining or
excuses um kind of to explain our life
he is he has a very inflexible schedule
that is shift work I work for a small
familyowned accounting firm so I have
flexibility which is one of the reasons
why I started working for it because
we're raising two kids
um but there's constant deadlines and
I'm managing you know a couple of people
and so when I leave or have the
flexibility um I still have to get the
work done whereas I imagine with his
work when the shift is over somebody
else is taking over that shift and
continuing the work it's not really like
that with my job
unfortunately um but I'm thankful for it
because I enjoy it and like I said
allows me to do things like today right
before this call I had to run back and
get a lunch for somebody who forgot it
at home um and honestly I think a lot of
times whenever I complain it's just
hoping for some compassion so that
whenever I do have to work nights or
weekend it's a little bit better
received yeah I don't know
so
I might be manipulation no I mean what
what you're mentioning now what you're
talking about now is is not at all how I
would Define best
friend cuz with your definition what
you're hoping your best friend is is a
trash
can for you to come empty all the crap
that happened to you today into a can
into a person and you want them just to
hear you and take it but I don't think
that's what you want you said it
perfectly I want some compassion I want
someone to see all of me both the
beautiful me that's the wife both both
like the Romantic partner the the um
awesome Mom side of me and like the
exhausted side because I'm busting my
butt too it just looks different than
the way you're busting it your
butt and that's not about being best
friends and that's not even coming home
and vomiting on
somebody
um it's really about two things one
creating boundaries about work from home
like and what a lot of us do when we
have work at home we bring the work home
we're mad that the work is there and
then we're mad at the rest of our family
for not realizing that I'm still at work
even though I'm at home the whole thing
just gets messy right right it's
different than saying from 5 o'clock
until 8 o'clock I'm going to be I'm
gonna have my mom hat on and wife hat on
and then I'm taking that hat off and
then from 8:00 to 11:00 p.m. I'm going
to be an
employee because that's that's the
arrangement I have that's what I have to
do right now for my particular job in
this particular moment and it allows you
to say I'm I'm code switching here but
I'm I'm a mom here and I'm I'm at home
here it's when you plop up with the
laptop and everyone's watching TV and
you're like hey y' be quiet I can't
figure this out or I'm not getting you a
snack it's you're trying to do both at
the same time and it never works that's
the first one the second thing is is
there's something deeper going on in
your marriage tell me about
that
because what what you just the picture
you just painted is very much a symptom
not the root
cause you and your husband are pretty
far apart
huh I mean I think so we we have been
through
counseling and there have been
improvements but there's still just
seems to be a disconnect like I don't
know I just feel like I'm constantly
criticized and when I say that to he
says well you're just misinterpreting
how I'm saying it don't listen to the
way that I'm saying it listen to my
words but it
feels not
supportive have you told him explicitly
the words that are helpful and the words
that are not
helpful
um CU a lot of times we want our spouses
to be mind readers
yes which is what he tells me all the
time I can't be a mind reader but I do
feel like whenever I have it's hard for
me to
express how I'm feeling really why is
why why why why is that is he not
safe or is that a skill you need to
learn because list I think a little bit
of both I mean he so before we got
married before he was diagnosed with um
add
which you know once he got some help for
that that did help with some anger but
um I I would say that sometimes I don't
feel emotionally safe
okay um he's a what does that
mean I I don't hear this at all I don't
hear this at all like you're talking bad
about him what I hear is you're speaking
Italian he's speaking Spanish and he's
trying to tell you as loudly as he can I
love you and you don't understand what
he's saying and VI and vice
versa that's probably true if he's going
to counseling with you and he's trying
to tell you hey just listen to what I'm
saying and don't interpret my body
language or this um then that sounds
like a guy who's trying and on the other
side of that um you have to take
ownership
of what you need from him and you have
to say those things out loud for
instance in a very similar situation
years AO go with my wife I had to say I
just need you to say the words I'm proud
of you thank you for working so hard and
she said in a in a roundabout ways like
all of your laundry just magically
appears in the thing and your kids
lunches are magically made and I you
know like go on dates with you and fill
in the blank all these things and I'm
like I know and behavior is a language
that's like one of my core sayings and I
get it would you just say those words
for
me and then she said absolutely yes and
I was ashamed and I was embarrassed to
say something like that out loud but it
needed to be said because I was just
getting frustrated that she never
acknowledges
me and so similarly I tell you that
about my life to tell you you're going
to have to be explicit this isn't
Hollywood and not every romantic comedy
I mean every romantic mood doesn't end
with like I can I I know what you're
thinking and saying it's going to take
you sitting down and saying when you say
these two things I shut
down and it's my nervous system that
leaves the building goes to fight or
flight and then I'm trying to recover I
can't be in relationship with
you when you say why don't you I'm
out that's why on this show and and so I
could get all nerded out and talk about
the nervous system all I don't think
that's as instructive as saying that's
why I'm always on the show telling
people look at your romantic partner in
the morning hold their hand and ask the
question how can I love you
today and if if your husband asked you
that on a random Tuesday and you knew
you had six hours of work after you got
home that night you could say tonight's
going to be chaos for me would you take
bed times and take the kids out to
dinner somewhere even though we can't
afford it we take the kids out to dinner
will you do bed times so I can fully
plug into this stuff so that I can be
fully present the rest of the
week that's a different request how can
I love you today and that's a different
full expression of what I need need and
what I what I want today um or how can I
love you today I'm feeling super
disconnected can we plan a super like
wallpaper coming off the walls sex night
tonight and we just text each other all
day about it got it right like let's be
super intentional about what we need and
let's have those conversations on the
front end and then give each other a
chance to show up because then if he
says I ain't doing that I ain't doing
bedtime tonight that's your fault for
working late well now you realize you
got a bigger issue in your
marriage and I think that has been the
response not I mean there have been
times when yes he's responded that way
but other times like he'll say well I
was already planning to do
this or you know I think when I have
tried to communicate in the past it just
hasn't been received well or you
know and and I think he is trying um so
I think two things can solve some of
that one is insane
Clarity no nothing left to guess it's a
chance okay my wife will tell me and if
you Google ADHD my picture comes up
right I'm a poster child she will say
Josephine needs to be in bed by
7:45 Hank has this assignment and like
it's very clear and for years she
thought a real invested dad would would
know these things would know what time
bedtime is and would know what time
whatever and as part of our rebuilding
the marriage from the floor up it was
hey dude I'm working so crazy I'm
disconnected from the operation of this
house that's on me and you and I have
never sat down and talked about what's
the best bed times for x and for y and
for Z and so I honestly don't know and
so I'm not trying to be a jerk I'm not
trying to be absent I don't know and she
was like oh my gosh I've been holding
you accountable for things you didn't
even know
and then here we go right so there has
to be insane Clarity and there's a
difference between coming home at 5:00
and being like I got a crazy night
tonight I need you to do bedtime and
whatever and him like dude I've already
told everybody that I'm coming over for
whatever and a Sunday night hey can we
do calendar tonight for the
week I'm pretty sure I'm GNA have a a
Bonkers week on Monday or
Tuesday or Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
I'm going to neede you this week
so as as clear as possible and as uiver
as possible or two huge helps there and
then the final one is man life happens
and adults have to be adults there's
going to be days you get hammered with a
project at noon do the next day and he's
going to have to just suck it up and be
a grown man and say I love you and I
love my kids and I love our family
system more than whatever I think I'm
going to go
do does that make sense yes it
does and I think I think
I KN I think I know this stuff but
sometimes it's application and head
knowledge versus heart knowledge it's
hard to it's so hard it's so hard Marie
and can I tell you it's so
unsexy it's so not how the movies
are right it's just not it's like you
text him like I have to work late and
he's like aha I'm gonna get candles and
dinner and the kids are magically going
to brush their teeth on their own like
it's just not how it works right because
he's working a shift and he's like
okay got it and he's on you got a boss
screaming at him and he's got whatever
and the insurance is due today and he's
got to get the oil changed like it's
just life is bananas outside of a
Hollywood
Theater right and most couples are
frustrated by putting sex on the
calendar most couples are frustrated
that they have to look at their romantic
partner the person they've made a human
with and say hey when you say these two
things I'm out my body shuts off I don't
I wish it didn't but it just does
a better way to ask me is fill in the
blank this this
clearly
and if you are very clear and you move
up River and he goes I ain't doing that
really hang out with my
boys your marriage is in trouble you
have a bigger issue that you got to face
headon you got to choose reality in that
moment if you're working a flexible job
in the flexibility comes at a cost which
is boundaries one of the things that
people learned when um we everybody was
working from home was that they never
got to go home from work and so we saw
these
astonishing people logged in working 17
hours a day because they have anything
else to do and we've slowly seen a
productivity decline because working
more doesn't mean working more working
more doesn't mean working effectively or
with good
good stuff and so it may be that this
flexible job is super cool and your kids
if they forget their lunch they forget
their lunch and they'll they won't
forget it twice unless mom comes and
takes it to him every time and the
flexibility might be coming at a cost of
the peace inside you inside your home
and so maybe something to look into um
but let's go with Clarity let's go with
way way way Upstream let's start there
and see if you can challenge him to meet
your needs that are very very clear and
by the way ask him how can I love you
this week what he might say I really
need to go be with the boys for a night
awesome go knock it out man go have fun
have the time of your life cuz if he
goes out and hangs out and goes and
plays softball or goes and does whatever
he does and long as long as it's not
fantasy sports no fantasy sports um or
like Ben Pokemon Card Collector you can
do that cuz those got a big RI on him
but like whatever it is just you're
going to get a better version of your
husband if he goes out and hangs out
with his friends unless those friends
are idiots and then that's a whole other
conversation but you know where I'm
going start with Clarity Clarity Clarity
Clarity start a Sunday night hey can we
go over the calendar this week what most
couples find is it's pretty much like
foreplay with gasoline on the fire when
you talk about your calendars together
well we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey folks delone here sometimes we
know what good for us but it feels like
we just can't make ourselves do it like
our brain's getting in its own way and
that happens to me a lot and I'm pretty
sure it happens to you I know I should
play a game with my kids instead of
practicing my guitar all night but
sometimes my brain tells me that hey
maybe that metal band's going to call
after all you got to get your practice
in therapy helps me figure out what's
holding me back from doing what I know I
should do and it can help you too so
your brain can begin to work with you
not against you sometimes it's just as
simple as talking things through and
learning how to intentionally Place
guard rails between yourself and
negative behaviors we call them
boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
better help visit betterhelp.com /one
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right let's go out to Dallas
Texas and talk to Jamie what's up
Jamie hi Dr John this is Jamie how are
you I'm great how are you I'm doing good
so my thank you for taking my call by
the way of course thanks for calling
what's up um my question is how do I Bal
working on getting out of debt an active
member of AA going to counseling and
being a good wife and
mother and um here's my backstory so I
met my husband during the beginning of
coid um we got married eight months um
after meeting which was January 10th of
2021 and both of us have children or or
I have a child from another relationship
his kids are now 23 18 and 16 years old
why I have a
20-year-old all all the kids live
outside our home uh we both brought debt
into our relationship and we're
currently working on baby step number
two and we've been making progress on
that by the way um we are both working
about 55 to 65 hours a week I struggled
with drinking alcohol which led to some
chronic um health issues I've been sober
since November 27th 2021 all right where
to go yeah yeah so like in two days
about to get your yeah you're about to
get your two-year chip here in a month
or two yeah congratulations man that's
awesome thank you it's been it's been
and when I and when I say I'm an active
member like I have a
sponsor I actually have a sponsy i chair
meetings I mainly go to women's meetings
but sometimes I do coed so like I'm
there like I'm working the program it's
not just oh yeah I go in once a time you
know I mean I'm I'm present so I show up
um and so it's been really hard work um
and I I go to counseling um and I know
that these changes have strengthened my
husband and I's
relationship even though I know being
debt free and staying sober is worth it
and it is worth it um there are days I I
just want to do nothing and start over
or just run I'm just tired
yes that feeling is that feeling is
right yeah yeah so that's my that's the
gist of it so hear me say this you're
not broken there's nothing wrong with
you if you weren't having those days I
would think you probably should see
somebody right
now right because the person who is
jaming is not working right
um how do you define be a good wife and
good mom because the things that you
just rattled off there that you're
trying to create peace in your home by
paying off all your debts and for those
of you who don't know baby step 2 is a
part of a program called Financial Peace
University and baby step 2 is a death
Sprint to sell everything to work like
crazy no restaurants nothing to pay off
everything you owe so that you don't owe
anybody except for your mortgage
um how long do you have to go on that
Jamie so we are tackling our lost credit
card I I when I looked at every dollar I
want to say um we had a little we
started off with a little over
100k and yeah it was a little bit of
everything that's all right that's all
right but where are you now where are
you now we're about 80 a little over
80,000 left or that's what we've paid
off that is how much we have left okay
so so you're 20% in right that's right
right correct very cool how long you
been working on it um well at first we
was kind of off and on but then we both
sold two expensive cars I missed a
Camaro but nobody misses a Camaro that's
the most Dallas thing I've ever
heard
I I uh guy who plays second string tight
end in his high school football team
that's who drives
Camaros right but we sold a 2021 Camaro
and a 2021 Trailblazer which took off a
lot of that and then um we also had a
lot of medical I had some significant
health issues hold on but hold on hold
on you're circling the question how do
you define being a good mom and a good
wife oh how do I
Define I guess being
I guess being
present okay but sometimes you're you're
in a fight for your life yeah and before
you can be present your body would be
failing you if it let you sit in peace
in your living room with your loved ones
knowing you owed a $100,000 in credit
card debt in car debt depreciating
assets it would be failing you if it
wasn't slowly sounding the alarms you're
not okay you're not okay you're not okay
right because you've been a few drinks
in and all a sudden something's
happening your body has a GPS pin in
that moment and it knows you can get
fired at any moment for anything right
and if you owe that kind of money then
they take everything right so your
body's doing exactly what it should be
and you're going to counseling and
working on how you re-experience the
world and you're going to AA and
learning from the from the foundation up
how to re-experience being
alive
right that's incredible there's not
going to be any balance in this season
than there shouldn't
be because you're running for your life
you're healing yeah you're growing it's
like looking down like after you got a
bad cut and it's and it's and it's got a
scab on it and you're like when does the
smooth skin arrive and it's like later
right it's still
healing and that doesn't the scab
doesn't mean it's it's broken and man
scabs are the worst when you bump them
and they start bleeding again
right or you scratch them through your
shirt because you just forget about it
and it bleeds into your shirt like the
worst and also it's a sign that your
body's healing you're on the
path here's what I think's
happening often when we make control alt
delete Life Changes I'm gonna start
losing weight I'm G to start a workout
plan I'm G to be a better husband I'm
GNA stop drinking I'm going to go to AA
I'm strugg goinging to counseling it
feels so freaking good for a week or
two right it's like you can take on the
world and then the reality sets in this
is every day for the rest of your
life and it's boring and it's annoying
and it's so frustrating and then slowly
but surely from underneath those
relationships and new programs the shame
demons come out and they're like if you
hadn't done this this long ago this
wouldn't happened and if you hadn't have
bought that you hadn't done this right
they're hollering at you yeah oh yeah so
it's a matter of we're going to get
through this we're going to pay off
everything we owe
so that we can our bodies can
go in our own living
rooms drop our shoulders and then you're
going to find balance restored in a
pretty powerful way but it's not going
to be balance like you think it's not
going to be painfree balance it's going
to be peace so that I you can handle the
nonsense as it comes has counseling
started getting
hard yeah it is because it's yeah
and I'm actually
um yeah so like
we're like just and one of the things
I'm working with my counselor is getting
more Tools in my toolbox as far as how
to work through anxiety or depression or
just perfect communication communication
with my husband and my kids and perfect
my relationship even with my
stepchildren and my biological child has
changed dramatically you know um and
good ways and so I've just been trying
to
learn how to do things different because
because the way you were doing them in
the past was going to kill you right and
right just know like you've started
playing football without a helmet on
right like you've been running through
life with a helmet on and the helmet was
alcohol and now you don't have that
anymore of course it's going to hurt the
first few times yeah right the first
time your step kid kid says something or
your husband's late getting home or fill
in the blank it's going to hurt more
because your your suit of armor is
gone right and man I'm so proud of you
for already noticing I just got to learn
some new tools I got to learn some new
tools as I head into this thing that's
fantastic hang on the line I'm going to
send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life my new book on anxiety
um and I'm also going to send you own
your past change your future just about
navigating some of those stories and
that's going to give you some language
you can talk to your counselor with
um I think the idea of balance is a
complete and utter myth it's nonsense
it's not real it's something sold to us
by the Pinterest Instagram
snap fancy magazine at your like health
food store community and I just lumped a
bunch of people that really have nothing
to do with it but all in the same bucket
here's the deal there's no such thing
you can't be a millionaire and show up
to every build a a million dollar
business and show up to every um L Le
game and be the perfect wife and make
sure you cook all the meals and have be
the perfect husband and make sure that
you never get frustrated and the lawn is
always perfect that's not real it's not
real it's not
real and so for me I'm on the road I go
hard go hard go hard go hard and then
this weekend I spent six hours mowing my
yard with a with a riding
mower CU it's six acres and it's a lot
and I'm just Mowing and Mowing and
mowing and I did it a good job on it but
there's no balance I couldn't do that
and do this and do this and do this I
can't so when you're getting out of debt
you're hauling you're running for your
life no
restaurants no no spending money on
dates we're going to go on free dates
and my God how many laps are around the
creek before the lake before you're like
GH you're so cheap like it's the worst
but it
is and you're going to work 55 hours a
week and then you might deliver pizzas
in the evening or drive lift in the
morning before work you're going to just
grind it until that $80,000 is zero and
it's going to start piling up and piling
up and piling up you've already knocked
off 20 something thousand bucks and
you're on your
way and then there's going to be peace
just in time for the next big whatever
crazy thing is going to
happen but trying to beat yourself up
because like I'm not a good mom because
I'm not in Balance no dude you're an
freaking amazing mom cuz you said this
hurt stops with me you're an incredible
wife because you looked at your husband
and said you deserve all of me and I got
to go find all of me first and so you're
going to AA you're going to counseling
I'm so proud of you doesn't get any
better than
that and you're learning some new skills
you're going to have to practice there's
going to be some up dayss and some down
days and that's okay you're doing a
great great
job stay on the
path even when you don't feel like it
even when it's frustrating even when
those old shame demons come screaming at
you stay on the path keep taking the
next step and the next step and the next
step they say an AA all the time it's
one day at a time it's one hour at a
time it's one minute at a
time that goes for any great things that
we pull off in our lives from changing
our marriages changing our finances from
changing our physical health all of it
I'm proud of you Jamie we'll be right
back
if you've listened to my show any amount
of time you've definitely heard me talk
about Thorne Thorne is an incredible
supplement company that makes what I
think are the best supplements in the
game I've taken Thorne for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming the next great
thing for all sorts of ailments almost
all of those claims and products are
either lying not good products are just
a waste of your money Thorne is one of
the very few supplement companies that
make Pure Clean tested and backed by
science supplements no fluff no gimmicks
no nonsense Thorn is what I take
personally and it's what I give to my
kids and make no mistake supplements of
this quality cost more than the nonsense
you see in gas stations so I've
partnered with Thorne for an incredible
25% off discount for our deloney show
listeners go to thorne.com
/ delone choose what you want add it to
your cart create an account and when you
check out 25% off will be knocked off of
the entire order and here's the best
part that discount sticks around for
Life go to thorne.com
thelet delone check it
out all right so we're back all right so
building a non-anxious life the book is
out and in the book I talk about six
daily choices weekly monthly yearly
choices that we can make on an ongoing
basis kind like brushing your teeth
we've all agreed that nobody can brush
their teeth so amazing on like a Tuesday
morning that they don't have to do it
again till Friday Ben but we know that
right you do it twice a day and you your
breath is mostly better and your teeth
don't fall out of your head and then if
you brush your teeth every day a couple
times a day you floss and then a year
from now suddenly your someone's like oh
you got bad breath and you know you got
an infection and you know you can go
deal with it right
similarly there's six things you can do
on an ongoing recurring basis and some
of them are huge at front if you have to
go deal with childhood um abuse it's
going to take a while if you got to pay
off all of your debts so that your brain
isn't constantly freaked out because
your mortgage loan officer is going to
tell you what you're going to do
tomorrow not you your toxic abusive boss
is going to tell you what to do not you
because you owe
money takes it some time but but once
you've navigated those Rough Waters
doing this stuff takes 10 20 30 minutes
a day and if you throw a workout in
there maybe an hour a day and so it's
not
a um it's not insurmountable in fact it
transforms your life and so what we did
was we got with an amazing film crew and
um with an awesome director we got with
a whole gang and we shot the six daily
choices um six of them yeah like that
the six daily choices there's six of
them I'm uh redundant how did you come
up with that it's brilliant I I just did
the calculations in my head real fast um
and so we're going to go through each
one of them in a segment over the next
six weeks um and we're going to just
drop them into each show uh not in each
show but into a random show over the
next six weeks and we're going to go
through them if you're on listening to
this on
podcast having putting the wrong empasis
on the wrong cabble if you're listening
to this on podcast um the audio is going
to be is is top-notch going to be great
if you want to also watch this on
YouTube um the visuals are amazing the
film crew did just an astounding job
they're awesome but it's the six daily
choices today we're going to be talking
about which one
Kelly today we're going to talk about
reality
choosing You' said that exact sentence
to me a lot a lot yeah well John today
we're gonna talk about reality we never
do you were failing in your job and
you're late
so today um the first of the six daily
choices choosing reality here we
go so I've come to believe one
critically important truth our bodies
are constantly solving for reality even
when we're
[Music]
not so I came out of a season where I
was super anxious I almost lost
everything right but I had everything at
the same time I had a great job I had a
good marriage I had healthy kids like so
everything was working except my body
was running and fighting everyone and
everything and then I remember landing
on a couple of data points that really
shook me more people in the United
States are under the care of a licensed
mental health professional right now
than ever before in human history and
more people are medicated for
psychological issues right now than ever
before in human history we've created a
world that our bodies cannot exist
so the first logical question that
anybody's going to ask is okay well what
do I do now where do I start to build a
non-anxious life the place we have to
begin is with reality you must choose
reality so when we're little we get this
picture of what life is supposed to look
like or sometimes we get a picture of
what life should never look like all of
these stories are mapped inside of us
from a very young age and then we
graduate high school and we turned 23 25
30 35 and all of a sudden we stop one
day and realize our life looks nothing
like this fantasy that we had built when
we were young people treated you
differently cuz you were the wrong color
in the wrong part of town you didn't
love the right way you were kicked over
this way or on the other side look at
all this money we're making I made
partner I got tenure I've got all these
certificates and
achievements and your kids want nothing
to do with you your wife has created a
life completely separate from you your
husband doesn't even know who you are
anymore whatever has happened in your
life there's a gap between what you
wanted to happen this life you imagin
this thing you're still aiming for
subconsciously in the the life you
actually
live Joo calls it extreme
ownership my buddy's dad called it
staring down the devil cuz you got to
look in the mirror and be honest about
your shortcomings honest about where
people hurt you you got to be honest
about your coping mechanisms and all of
that is brutal choosing reality is about
putting it all on the table the good the
bad the abuse all of it so we're going
to back up and we're going to pause and
we're going to take a deep breath and
we're going to
Exhale we're going to choose reality
where are we right
now that gap between what is and what we
so desperately hoped for and long for
but
isn't that Gap is
grief if you leave with one truth know
this there is is no
life without
hurt you didn't think you were going to
owe this much money you didn't think you
were going to have to move you didn't
think that your marriage would be
hanging on by a thread you didn't think
she would leave
you and here we
are there is no path without
hurt you cannot go It
Alone our bodies aren't designed to
handle sadness and isolation our bodies
aren't designed to head into grief alone
and so choosing reality is about not
trying to deny the fact that you're
going to hurt you are and since you're
going to hurt you have to invite grief
along you got to invite the feelings
that associate with grief like sadness
disappointment
frustration and as great scientists have
found with sadness comes incredible
accuracy with disappointment with
frustration in the Smoke of what feels
like like everything has burned to the
ground you can finally see clearly for
the first
time so we head into grief because on
the other side of grief there's boldness
strength action cuz my body is healing
cuz I've got people on either side of me
and in front of me and behind me I can
go defend and protect and walk ahead the
only path to a non-anxious life right
through the middle of real
ity you have to take an honest inventory
of where you are you got to measure it
how's your
marriage how are your kids when's the
last time you went to a doctor and got a
blood workup when's the last time you
went to a dentist and I know you can't
afford it so how's your
money how much money do you
owe give any money in savings or is Visa
and Master Card your savings
plan all these things become a part of
you and your body's not going to let you
sleep your body's not going to let you
rest your body's not going to want you
to be intimate because it's trying to
survive so you got to take an
inventory so over the last few years my
life has changed my family's life has
changed and so is my bank account so is
my friend Circle so is how much I'm on
the road and how little I'm sleeping so
I thought I would be the hero and I went
and called the local counselor who I
trust and I sat down and one hour turned
into two and one counseling session
turned into the next week and the next
week and here I was finding myself
saying things that I had never said out
loud in my entire life in an effort to
tell everybody how to live a non-anxious
life I had created an incredibly anxious
one
myself so this whole experience for me
went from telling how to have a
non-anxious life to pulling up a seat
next to you and saying let's figure this
thing out together but here's my
promise there's light on the other side
of this thing I'm sleeping better my
marriage is better I'm a better parent
I'm a better
friend but choosing reality that's your
starting line that's where we
begin
hey what's up deloney here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful non anxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right so that was choosing reality
and as we wrap up today's show I did not
know this but boy was Kelly into the
Camaro and the boys who drove them they
tuck their jeans into their
boots no they don't they put on nothing
but a good time that's one of your
favorites that is true what is a good
Camaro
song Sweet Home
Alabama could see that yeah anything
skard really yeah it just feels like
skinnard is the soundtrack to America's
Camaro problem cut off like shirts with
the cut off sleeves they Fleck so hard
their sleeves just burst burst off yeah
but cut way down yeah yeah so you can
see their like their weird moles down
their ribs so
gross no man their jeans in their in
their boots
and like the little things there's
always something hanging from the
rearview mirror and you're like why
don't you just put it in the back and
they have to go like it won't fit back
there because this is a completely
impractical vehicle to drive around but
dude I look awesome and you're like I
love you it's cool so by the great
Weezer the song is called yellow Camaro
Kelly pres preferred the red ones or the
black Trans Ams with the eagle on the
front but yellow Camaro when the wheels
are in motion for Good Times Kelly's
there God bless the US assembly line
Kelly's there it's a game when you play
with high octane that's the pace of the
race we're following right on yellow
Camaro right
on the number of times I've heard Kelly
in the parking lot with a fist to the
sky looking at the at the uh American
flag just going right on yellow Camaro
man if I had a dollar for every time
I've seen that be rich I love you guys
stay in school
bye